20-17 has been a huge year for nintendo
especially on the zelda front between
breath of the wilds launch and it's
fantastic expansions there's a lot to
see and do I'm Tony and this GameSpot
news update is in development breath of
the wild masterworks is a book only
available in Japan for now and it
includes tidbits about the games
development cycle plus plenty of early
concept art but there's one particular
note that stands out series producer
Eiji Aonuma says that development on the
next zelda game has already begun now
don't get too excited breath of the wild
cycles started immediately after Skyward
Sword and there was still a six-year gap
there but in any case breath of the wild
will have a successor at some point in
the future speaking of which the game's
second expansion the champions ballad is
out now and you can always check out our
review if you want to know what's coming
your way with the new quest shrines and
bosses but if you're curious about how
it stacks up against some of the other
big titles of 2017
stay tuned a game spot as we continue
our game of the year countdown this week
you
[Music]